Et toi avec Fred, ça va bien ?
Putain mais ça se passe trop bien quoi.
Tu sais que je flippais qu'on emménage ensemble.
Et en fait  euh... Ben ça se passe grave bien.
Bonjour mon amour.
Je file à la douche, ok ?
T'as le temps pour un petit câlin ?
Ben bien sûr.
Ben c'est trop cool, trop bien.
Et t'as toujours pas le Hic ?
De quoi ?
Tu sais le Hic.
Tu sais c'est quand y a des trucs qui commencent à t'énerver ou à te dégoûter
chez quelqu'un avec qui tu restes un petit peu trop, t'as pas ça ?
Mais franchement mec y a qu'à toi que ça arrive ce genre de trucs.
Non.
Je sais pas, je suis hyper amoureuse de Fred,
pourquoi y auraient des trucs qui me dégoûtent ?
C'est dingue comme t'es pessimiste tu vois,
tu peux pas croire que juste une relation, roule, normal.
Si si, excuse-moi.
Coucou mon amour.
Hey sweety.
Ça va bien dormi ?
Ben tu sais, le Hic.
Quand y a des trucs qui commencent un peu à t'énerver.
Des petits trucs qui commencent à te dégoûter.
Chez quelqu'un avec qui tu restes un petit peu trop.
Le Hic.
Je viens de te dire que je suis hyper amoureuse de Fred,
Pourquoi y aurait des trucs qui me dégoûteraient ?
Il me dégoûte.
Tu peux pas croire qu'une relation, hé bien, juste elle marche ?
Je ne le supporte plus quoi.
Chez quelqu'un avec qui tu restes un petit peu trop.
Ça te dit un petit câlin ?
Qu'est-ce que tu m'as fait ?
Bonjour Zoé !
Putain mais qu'est-ce que tu m'as fait ?
Ok...
Alors ?
Bon, le truc dont tu m'as parlé l'autre fois là, le Huc !
Le Hic.
Ouais.
Hé bien, je crois que je l'ai.
Ah bon ?
Mais tu me disais qu'avec Fred tout allait bien je comprends pas.
Mais tout va bien, tout va bien avec Fred.
Mais je sais pas, je le supporte plus quoi.
Je supporte plus la manière qu'il a de manger.
Je te jure, j'ai jamais entendu quelqu'un faire autant de bruit avec sa bouffe quoi.
Putain, qui est le con qui a inventé les biscottes ?
Et puis cette façon qu'il a tu sais de dire :
CÂLIN, CÂLIN comme un con avec son accent de merde là !
T'es né à Cergy pauvre con !
Et tu sais ce que c'est le pire ?
C'est qu'il a...
Une crotte de nez là, en plein milieu, ici là
T'avais remarqué ?
On a tous remarqué Zoé.
Putain mec, je suis tellement dans la merde !
Je suis tellement dans la merde, on vient d'emménager ensemble là quand même !
Non mais c'est tout simple, quitte-le, c'est pas grave, tu peux le quitter.
Je vais pas le quitter parce qu'il mange des biscottes !
Bon j'ai peut-être une solution...
Mais je te préviens,
c'est définitif.
Bonjour mon amour.
Oh ben désolé j'ai oublié de me brosser les dents ce matin, c'est con.
C'est pas grave.
Tu manges le matin maintenant ?
Ouais, j'ai décidé de m'y mettre.
Non mais c'est, c'est super hein.
C'est important de manger le matin de toute façon.
Et euh... Ça te dit, une petit câlin ?
Ah ouais une petit cunnilingus !
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Ah pardon bébé mais elle a un goût super chelou là.
Ah bon ? C'est bizarre.
Ben ouais, tu veux pas....
Te rincer ou te laver...
Ouais non mais attends ça marche trop tes conneries là, il a déjà l'air à bout.
Franchement je bouffe comme un porc depuis des mois,
j'ai même une crotte de nez que je me colle tous les matins sur le bout du nez,
Je pue question hygiène tu verrais mes caleçons franchement on dirait une déchetterie.
Non, elle doit être à fond, je sais pas, elle veut pas me quitter.
Hé ben bravo !
Bienvenue chez les célibataires.
Comme quoi l'amour ça tient pas à grand chose hein.
Du coup tu... Tu t'es mis du vinaigre dans la chatte ?
Mouais.
Yes...
Stylé.